This video was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn for free for two months by being one
of the first 500 to sign up at skl.sh/wendover4.
The Arctic is warming.
That is not an assumption, a belief, a theory,
or a political stance.
That is an empirical fact based on empirical
data.
Just in 2018, based off the average between
1958 and 2002 the yearly average temperature
in the Arctic should have been this, but in
reality it was this.
One year is not a trend but here was 2017,
here was 2016, 2015, 2014, and 2013.
In 2017, overall annual Arctic air temperatures
were 2.9 degrees Fahrenheit or 1.6 degrees
Celsius above average.
That may not seem like much but that small
difference is like if Paris’ climate changed
to that of Istanbul.
Humans have lived in the Arctic for tens of
thousands of years, it’s far from impossible,
but it is difficult.
We’re no strangers to living in difficult
places—humans survive on islands days away
from civilization; in deserts nearly completely
devoid of natural resources; and in places
like the Arctic where cold and darkness create
some of the most rugged conditions on earth.
At least some of us seem to enjoy living in
tough conditions.
Where humans are lazy, in a sense, though,
is economically.
When there’s an option to get the same for
less, we’ll almost always take it.
The Arctic is an enormous area with plenty
of natural and human resources but it’s
also a harsh and isolated place meaning there’s
always been the same options for less, at
least until now.
Traditionally, the Arctic has been far from
a center of economic activity.
For example, the Canadian territory of Nunavut
has a gross domestic product of just $2 billion
USD.
That means that, despite being the largest
province or territory composing 21% of Canada’s
land area, Nunavut only makes up 0.13% of
the national economy.
The same is true elsewhere in the Arctic.
Alaska makes up 16% of the US’ land but
only 0.27% of its economy.
The Finnish region of Lapland makes up 27%
of the country’s land but only 2.5% of its
economy.
In perhaps the most staggering example, Greenland
has a physical size larger than that of Mexico
and yet its economy is smaller than that of
the tiny island country of Aruba.
However, its this very desolation, both physically
and economically, that’s spurring new Arctic
industries.
Emptiness is an asset.
This space is being filled by those seeking
isolation.
Tourism has established itself as the first
of two major sectors growing in the Arctic.
For example, Finland’s Lapland region has
seen double digit tourism growth over recent
years.
This area has particularly benefited from
the attention it receives from Europe’s
package holiday industry.
Particularly in the month leading up to Christmas,
charter flights by companies like Thomas Cook
and TUI will leave from nearly every UK airport
to far north Lapland airports like Kittilä,
Rovaniemi, and Ivalo.
Tourists come to visit destinations like Santa
Claus Village, an amusement park that bills
itself as the home of Santa, as well as engaging
in outdoors activities such as snowmobiling,
dogsledding, and skiing.
With the relative ease of visiting these destinations
via direct flights from destinations around
Europe and especially the UK, package tour
companies even sell day-trips to the Arctic.
One flies out from somewhere like London in
the morning, visits Santa Claus Village, and
flies back in the evening.
Of course, this tourism industry, despite
its rapid growth, has its shortcomings.
About 44% of all yearly arrivals happen in
December and January making it highly seasonal
so the region has put efforts into attracting
more spring, summer, and fall visitors.
Lapland has nonetheless decided that tourism
is likely its most promising driver of growth
so it has placed this industry at the forefront
of its economic development efforts.
This promise of tourism has been identified
by other Arctic areas, as well.
Visits are increasing steadily in Alaska,
the Yukon, the Northwest Territories, Nunavut,
Svalbard, it’s tough to find an Arctic region
where tourism isn't growing.
While at a much smaller scale than places
like Alaska or Lapland, Greenland has made
moderately successful efforts to expand tourism
as well.
It has seen healthy growth rates from 181,000
nights stayed by tourists 20 years ago to
263,000 today.
Like many places in the Arctic, though, it
suffers from accessibility issues.
It’s just hard to get to Greenland.
There are really only two ways to travel there
from the outside world—via the three hour
turboprop flight from Reykjavik or the four
hour jet flight from Copenhagen.
Both options are expensive with the flight
from Reykjavik or Copenhagen to Nuuk, Greenland’s
capital, costing around, at best, $800.
There are no day trips to Greenland.
This is part of the reason why much of the
growth in tourism both in Greenland and the
rest of the Arctic uses another means of transport—cruise
ships.
In another video we’ve covered how the warming
of the arctic is melting sea-ice and opening
up new maritime routes.
This is making it far easier for large cruise
ships to sail through Arctic waters into small
northern towns.
Now, Arctic cruises have happened for decades
to a certain extent but in the past they were
always done by ships like this—small expedition
style vessels with strengthened hulls to withstand
ice.
In 2016, though, the beast of Arctic cruises—the
northwest passage route through the Canadian
archipelago from the Pacific to the Atlantic—was
completed by this ship—the Crystal Serenity.
Thanks to the lower ice levels, it’s now
possible to sail large, traditional ships
through this route.
The Crystal Serenity is a regular cruise ship
built with a regular hull just like every
other cruise ship.
Unlike the smaller ships of before, this one
carried 1,000 passengers through the high
Arctic in comfort with onboard restaurants,
a spa, theatre, casino, and more.
When making voyages like this, ships typically
make stops in some of the tiny Alaskan, Canadian,
and Greenlandic towns along the route.
One of the most popular stops is the town
of Pond Inlet.
Normally the only way in here is via the three
hour flight from Iqaluit that costs well over
$1,000 roundtrip but a few times a year tourists
just wake up a couple hundred feet off its
shore.
Only 1,600 people live in Pond Inlet and yet
in 2018 eighteen cruise ships stopped in the
town carrying over 3,200 passengers.
That’s up from ten ships in 2015, nine in
2016, and thirteen in 2017.
For a small town of 1,600, especially one
like Pond Inlet with a 22% unemployment rate,
the significance of thousands of the kind
of tourists willing to pay tens of thousands
for an Arctic cruise visiting is enormous.
The local governments runs programs to help
develop businesses to cater to cruise guests,
stores stock up on products to sell to visitors,
and dozens gain temporary employment to help
coordinate the tourist’s shore visits.
Then, on a rapid-fire basis in August and
early September, the only time period when
the northwest passage is navigable, ships
show up just off the coast of Pond Inlet and
dozens of other northern Canadian and Alaskan
towns every few days.
The economic benefit of these visits is indisputable—Pond
Inlet earned $250,000 in docking fees in 2018
in addition to the benefit local businesses
and employees received.
It’s not all good news, though.
Due to the enormous price of shipping goods
to Arctic towns like Pond Inlet, most of the
indigenous residents hunt whale, seal, caribou,
and other indigenous animals to feed their
families.
There’s little hard research on its effect
yet, but many are concerned about these large
ships driving away animals and changing hunting
grounds.
This is in addition to the effect climate
change itself is already having.
There are also some concerned about poorer
air quality from ship exhaust, pollution from
ship discharge, for the safety of passengers
in an emergency considering the limited search
and rescue capability, and with the preservation
of these local cultures.
Just like the nature around them, the isolation
of these towns has kept the traditions and
customs of these communities alive in the
modern era and one can imagine what it’s
like to have 1,000 tourists suddenly show
up in a town of 1,600 that’s used to having,
at most, a few dozen outsiders there at a
time.
The Arctic wants economic development, but
they don’t want these towns to turn into
tourist destinations.
Most want the cruise ships to come, but they
also want to keep the surroundings unspoiled.
One comes at the cost of the other so it’s
all just a balancing act of interests.
There are, though, more heavily weighted scales
balancing the economy and the environment.
According to estimates, this area, the Arctic,
holds 13% of the world’s undiscovered oil.
That represents 90 billion barrels which,
at current prices, are worth more than $4
trillion.
The thing is, it doesn’t really make sense
to drill in the Arctic right now.
That’s because, in the Arctic, to drill
that barrel of oil which, in January, 2019,
is selling for $46, it costs about $78.
That’s compared to costs as low as $29 per
barrel with onshore drilling in the Middle
East.
Whereas in the Middle East all you have to
do is build an oil rig, in the Arctic, where
there’s limited infrastructure, for offshore
drilling, one has to build a rig, get icebreaker
ships, establish a port, set up a transportation
and supply network, and more.
In some ways, therefore, Arctic ice melt is
helping reduce these costs as it’s easier
for ships to move around both to explore for
oil and serve rigs.
In other ways, though, this is adding difficulties
as less ice leads to larger waves which require
bigger, more expensive boats to navigate which
sometimes require dredging in the shallow
waters of some oil-rich locations.
Right now, Arctic oil drilling is sort-of
in a holding pattern until oil prices increase
or drilling costs decrease enough for it to
become economically viable.
As a whole, though, in the long-term, Arctic
warming decreases cost for the oil and gas
industry as it makes the area look and act
more like the cheaper and warmer south.
The economic impact for other industries is
more of a mixed bag, though.
For example, fishing represents a large proportion
of the current Arctic economy and, while some
species of fish will grow in number due to
warmer waters others will slowly disappear.
In mining, the opening of sea routes will
make transportation cheaper but the industry
actually benefits from having the frozen,
permafrost land which is disappearing since
it gives a stable platform for equipment and
therefore makes set-up less expensive.
In fact, land transportation infrastructure
in general, including airports, is expected
to deteriorate rapidly as permafrost melts
and land becomes less stable.
The tourism industry, which does benefit from
the easier access and increased activity in
the Arctic, suffers too from Arctic warming.
In November, 2018, Lapland lacked any snow
due to unseasonably high temperatures which
led to mass trip cancellations by tourists
who booked their trips to see the traditionally
snowy Arctic.
Tourists come for the winter weather so a
future without snow in the region is potentially
a future without tourism in Lapland.
In addition, the pristine natural environment
is the asset of the Arctic tourism industry
so an Arctic without that pristine natural
environment is one without its tourism industry.
Even ignoring the irreversible, disastrous
consequences the warming of the Arctic is
already having on polar bears and caribou
and fish and walruses and reindeer and all
the other native Arctic species, this circle
is home to four million people.
The Arctic plus a few more degrees is an Arctic
that has fundamentally changed the way these
four million people live and work and that’s
an Arctic that may no longer be truly home
to them.
The people, animals, and environment of the
Arctic, in a metaphorical sense, are situated
between two, massive, slow-moving icebergs.
One is the power of climate change and the
other is the the power of the economy.
Climate change could possibly be slowed or
stopped or reversed but only with great effort
by more than just the people of the Arctic.
On the other side, the power of economic pushes
and pulls is perhaps just as difficult to
stop.
If it makes economic sense for industries
to be in the Arctic, they’re almost certainly
going to be in the Arctic even if it means
environmental ruin.
These two massive, slow-moving icebergs are
on their collision course with the Arctic
already and, it might just be too late to
stop them.
The physical, economic, and social landscape
of the Arctic is going to change.
This might be a story without a happy ending.
The only positive note to end on is that,
while riding the sinking ship, there’s at
least a chance to make money on the way down.
If you ever get the chance to visit the Arctic,
which, as someone who’s been there, I highly
recommend if you have the opportunity, the
number one thing you should bring is a camera
to capture the stunning landscapes and distinctive
towns.
Before heading off, though, you should brush
up on your photography skills with Skillshare’s
landscape photography class.
Using their iOS or Android apps, you can even
download the classes offline for the flight.
Of course, to go the Arctic you first need
the time so, in order to streamline your work
processes and improve your productivity, you
should also take their “Productivity Masterclass”
course by fellow YouTuber and all-around nice
guy Thomas Frank.
In addition to these two, Skillshare has about
22,000 courses so it’s the perfect place
to go for those with varied interests.
Best of all, you can take either and all of
these courses for free for two months by being
one of the first 500 to go to skl.sh/wendover4.
Also, one last note, I recently got an Instagram
to post personal updates and behind-the-scenes
photos of all the travels I do to make these
videos so if that sounds interesting to you,
you can go follow it at instragram.com/sam.from.wendover.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you again
in two weeks for another Wendover Productions
video.